hello everybody you are good first of
all thank you very much for all your
messages and support especially in the
last 24 hours I'm really glad that
you're liking the content here so that's
why I'm going to continue with the daily
updates because I appreciate it so
basically Bitcoin just left this Zone
that we marked this was the weekend
range it was a sort of choppiness but we
were expecting was
a move first to the to the week or to
the liquidity pool the liquidity pool
came first as that was our main scenario
because that's where there was more
liquidity so it would make sense that if
everybody goes going short that they
trigger this liquidations over here so
then more people would jump into shorts
and then they could reverse to the
opposite side okay so that's pretty much
what happened I'm gonna show you here
this hit
26140 and if we go to the liquidation
hit map in Cabo capital
we can see that they took that
liquidation so you can see with that
week there and then price change
direction okay so that was what we were
expecting with the premise that after
that bounce Bitcoin had to close again
above the 50 daily EMA and that's what
happened let's go to the 50ma
here you can see this purple line is the
50 daily EMA so basically this was the
the Candlestick you can see the price
went down and then came back up and the
daily candle closed above the daily 50
EMA so that's perfect that's what
happened and then if we go back to the
one hour time frame we can see
the the next Direction was the week the
Haku you enter that trade because we
have a problem and is that Bitcoin was
below low time frame resistance the 1
hour 50ma so what we were basically
expecting was
a bounce break above the deli the 1 hour
50ma test the bucket support that's what
happened here and then bounce okay I'm
very happy that it played out now
Bitcoin keeps moving up let me remove
all of this because we've left this Zone
so this is not interesting anymore
okay and we don't need the 50ma neither
so Bitcoin keeps going up now and now
you might be wondering what is next
I'm also very interested to see what
Bitcoin does up here because that's
exactly thirty thousand that's a
psychological number so let's see what
Bitcoin does that okay what I'm
expecting basically is that look it's
almost there is that it breaks above it
okay
so people are gonna get very bullish
because they've just gone above a very
psychological
level Okay so
what I imagine is that it's going to go
up then retrace
and then see what it does here because
from here we could see a lot of Wicks to
the upside
operation any further and then Bitcoin
could retrace okay or we could see the
same that it has done here that has been
doing a bit of consolidation by making
higher lows you can see here we're gonna
go in a minute and then continue going
up okay but yes I expect that in around
the 30k above 30 I would say between
thirty thousand two hundred thirty
thousand five hundred
some kind of consolidation okay now I
want to check this Zone because I want
you to understand the difference with
what I meant here
okay
and what happened here so let me check
this
view to the 15 minutes time frame
you can see that there was no reason to
short here why were you sure this price
is making is still higher lows you can
see here here here here here so what
were you sure there
it doesn't make any sense okay what we
would like to see
for a short signal is something similar
to this but we won't basically
price
in a Range are at the highest and doing
some kind of this okay then we're
probably gonna have here a strong
resistance so what we like is a stop
hunt and then a retrace but for that
Bitcoin is not giving us a sign for any
of that so I'm not going to trade this
but you could do those you could go to
the five minutes time frame and you can
start looking for wicks look at this one
for example you had a long week here
okay and then a long week here so what
you could expect here
is this week to get filled at least 50
percent and aim towards this week this
is what I mean with a scalping in low
time frame okay that is always
opportunities but at the moment look
again this week are filled at the moment
is that your scalp
or do wait for the New York opening
so that's pretty much everything that I
have to say for Bitcoin at the moment
if you trade right now I would call that
over trading because that is nothing
that is indicating me a high probability
trade okay we want a trade that plays
out like for example yesterday's we were
planning that trades in the Sunday
update and it happened yesterday but
that's a high probability trade that's
what we want
okay so now either scalp in low time
frame or wait for the New York opening I
have a very clear guys I want to go to
the SMP
because he's doing some kind of
move over here look at this
do you guys remember this box that we
were pointed at at 4100 okay and what
would happen
if the SMP lost this Zone
yep
it's not looking great
I mean still there is some kind of
support here you can see in this Zone
okay so let's see if the SMP can hold
this Zone because if not it has a long
way down to four thousand okay I'm also
paying attention to the earning reports
and the News announcements yesterday
after the markets closed we had the end
report from Google and
Microsoft and they were better than
expected today we have meta after the
market closes and tomorrow we have
Amazon okay so that's going to be quite
interesting but what it's even more
interesting is what happened in the US
First Republic Bank
yesterday dropped 49 percent the value
of the stock okay basically they
admitted the they lost a lot of deposits
which is normal so the banking crisis
hasn't finished okay I'm gonna go to the
year deals just see the two deer deals
chart
there we go higher time frame for our
time frame
okay I see that's pretty interesting
so basically it has abandoned this
uptrend now it's retracing okay I like
to think that what is interesting here
is that the bonds Market is not really
trusting and believing the FED because
the FED keeps saying that in 10 days
well eight days now we'll have the fomc
meeting May 3rd
They're Gonna Keep increasing rates but
we have
the problem of the banking crisis that
hasn't finished and if they keep Rising
interest rate is gonna make it worse
okay probably now they wanna have to
rescue the bank
and then we have the bonds Market
that has predicted the top well
according also to the Dot Plot
from the fat
and it's not really trusting what they
are saying about keeping interest rates
higher and Rising them okay because
otherwise what I would have done here is
first he would have gone to fill this
Gap
and then keep Rising a mega higher high
we may be 525 but it hasn't so let's see
what effect does when we are closer to
the date of the fomc meeting
I'll give you some more information but
it's good to always keep an eye on those
announcements the ponds Market Behavior
and what is happening around the glove
okay so thank you so much for watching
guys I'll see you soon